well let's jump to the story from sr.com
shout out to our good friend Anna
casparian she has called for the Asylum
Seekers who attacked police to be
deported immediately this story is wild
I believe it was five criminal aliens
mercilessly beat a couple police
officers and were released immediately
without bail and I sit back and I put my
feet up and I go well okay what's the
problem you got what you voted for well
anyway now Kathy hok is saying they they
should be deported and anak casparian
said they should be deported immediately
I love the Asylum Seekers I didn't know
that uh we used those terms here but I
suppose if it's true it's true because B
was discussing a mob of Asylum
Seekers I wonder is it on purpose
Cassandra all like they all can be like
I am seeking Asylum thank you even if
they're here illegally I'll tell you how
I take it it's like taking the Asylum
Seeker the left likes to say and then
saying was a violent mob that brutally
attacked police officers you know what I
mean anyway they attacked two New York
cops in Times Square Saturday night
seven were arrested and quickly released
without bail the progressive YouTube
personality responded on her show by
saying that seeking Asylum here is a
privilege not a right let's see we have
we have a clip here I don't if it's too
long I don't want to play the full thing
if we can even get it to
play Let's uh let's do that and open it
up on the the old X and see if it'll
play there these are not people you need
to provide cover for these are people
who are in the country claiming Asylum
they don't have a right to be here it is
a privilege to be able to take advantage
of of our Asylum program and people so
the left is now saying it is a right not
a privilege uh anaran is correct and I
got a couple things to say um I'll
stress Asylum is a privilege we offer
you and we don't have to we are nice
people I ain't got no reason to let
anybody in my house if I'm a nice person
I'll try and help them out the second
thing is congratulations Anna you
deserve these people because you lie all
the time so have fun uh I'll agree with
you on the political message I won't
disagree on what you're saying but I I
I'm not going to uh uh I'm not going to
provide defense for someone like Anna
who lies on her show particularly about
me and when the left comes and is mad at
her good these are your allies and your
friends so bend the knee or shut up cuz
I ain't coming your defense she's got a
point though I I mean it's if
you're once upon a time when people used
to come to our country seeking Asylum
it's because they were really running
from something that was like life or
death they were seeking salvation what
if you're Canadian or Mexican I'm saying
if that's the situation you're in maybe
on day one don't come in the country and
start beating up police officers well if
you're Canadian or Mexican okay if
you're from Honduras what is what you
you go to Mexico you're supposed to stop
at the next country that that can offer
you Asylum instead they're like we're
just going to keep going till we get to
America like if you're in dire need you
don't just like continue on forever and
ever if if I'm a if if I was elected
Supreme Chancellor the first thing I
would do is I I would immediately bang
the gavl and say Asylum only app lies to
people who come from countries
neighboring the United States If you
flew here my question is why did you
choose here sorry bye-bye if you came
here from Mexico and you said here's
what's happening we'll review your case
and I got to tell you this if everybody
who came here came to the border and
said I am seeking Asylum and they were
all Mexican I'd be willing to actually
bring them in and say okay you can come
in we'll find you a place we'll set up a
date for your hearing because they're
actually from a country where we
understand there there are political
issues cartels people have been killed
and the number would be substantially
less the problem now is they're coming
from Africa yeah they're flying from
Africa to Brazil taking these these a
mult it cost like 10 grand to do and
then they get to the American board and
they go um Asylum and it's like bro you
passed through 17 countries to get here
right you're you're done you were
running from a burglar bro he's 50 mil
away there's people in umaa talking
about paying uh they're they're coming
across the border paying people to carry
their Louis Vuitton luggage they're
flying weird it's very and this the same
thing people fly into Canada and cross
through the northern border I mean we
did bring in a certain number of Asylum
Seekers after Biden's botch withdrawal
from Afghanistan right we had we said
these are people who we've now put in
danger they worked with our government
and we brought them here but the pro for
me the issue with Asylum and I want to
be as compassionate as possible is that
we are saying ultimately we're allowing
you to stay here we're not saying that
we're going to let you stay here for a
couple years and eventually when your
country stabilizes you can go back
ultimately we we're just saying this is
a form of immigration that we allow and
I think that's part of the misleading
narrative there's sort of this pretend
like ultimately you'll be reunified with
your country but actually probably not
you're just here for good we need to be
more honest about what the things that
we are offering the people who come into
this country are I just I just think
it's it's disloyal it's it's not good to
mislead the American voters there are
not that many Mexican citizens relative
to all of the other countries and so if
someone comes here and they can make a
legitimate let's just say a a
preliminary claim we can say
okay right now what's happening is Joe
Biden's ad the Biden Administration is
opening up the gates destroying state
property and saying everybody just
whatever have fun and they never show up
for the Asylum they are not Asylum
Seekers that is just absolutely not true
and so this is still propaganda
anakasparian saying Asylum Seekers It's
not a right it's a privilege already
Shifting The Narrative they are criminal
aliens who have lied to exploit our
system and are committing crimes
it is not a right y'all can go uh put
get the ice buses and send them back to
their home countries they are not
seeking Asylum but the the the the side
point of course is anak kasparian has
and numerous occasions now along with
Jen yuger come out with positions that
are anti-leftist
probably because they saw the writing on
the wall I think The Young Turks realize
that you know the immigration issue what
was what was the other issue that came
out on crime crime and immigration ain't
winning you any friends yeah and so the
left is pro- crime and pro- illegal
immigration they are I'm not I'm not
trying to exaggerate they are they they
literally make sure to say be gay do
crime you're not going to be able to
come out and tell me they oppose it so
therefore for it you're going to lose
elections I think uh Jen Huger and anak
casparian want to win power for their
political faction but sorry you are you
are now your political faction is is
cohabitating with far-left extremists
who want to see the country burn right
has Eric Adams said anything about this
yet like I I I'm curious haven't checked
today I just saw Hog's comments you know
cuz he's he he's been like surprisingly
open vocal about the problem with the IL
illegal immigration and he's open about
it but also he I think should do more
with the Cy surrounding him so for a
while he was just in the middle of the
night bsing people to hotels in the
surrounding counties and it was the
County Commissioners there saying we
don't want this we didn't ask for this
you're the one who said that New York
was a sanctuary City and now you're
making it so it's our bir as well uh and
this was true I mean hok has also helped
uh disperse illegal immigrants
throughout the state and I think that is
sort of this interesting uh Dynamic
they've put themselves in you have hok
you have uh Adams who are actually
making it I mean I'm sure there's always
a little bit of tension between you know
more rural New York and New York City
but there is even more tension now when
they're saying you guys let us into this
position we can't afford or want to deal
with this and yet you think you have the
right to just say well all of your
communities are inferior to ours and can
serve our needs remember they were they
were flying in illegal immigrants
Westchester White ples which is just nor
for those who don't know just north of
the city what would you do question for
anybody if you were the mayor of a city
seeing an influx of illegal immigrants
build a wall I don't know what if you're
the mayor of the city yeah you're Eric
Adams right now what do you
do can you Deport everybody I mean yeah
that's that's my question I so like put
him on a bus and send him to Los Angeles
yeah you sh them back to the Texas
border uh I I think one of the things is
just because I don't totally know what
resources are available to Mayors is
that you would hopefully need to have a
governor who is like yes we will remove
them we will support you because
theoretically your local law enforcement
like if you're the mayor of a small town
you don't necessarily have all the
resources to say we're getting you out
of here you know for those that have
played balers Gate 3 there's this really
great scenario which you don't need to
know the game to understand where um the
game has three acts in act three you
make your way to a city called balder's
gate it's a city and it is being
besieged there's a war going on refugees
are pouring in and there's uh right when
you get into the outskirts of the city
which you could describe as the suburbs
I suppose there's a guy arguing with
squatters who are refugees saying your
house is empty it's ours and you choose
who to side with the guy who owns the
house who is traveling and comes back to
find his house occupied or the squatters
it's up to you there's a character in
the game named Menara she is an
authoritarian uh I guess you right I
guess she's a paladin who thinks like
she's just like a brutal dictatorial
kind of personality there's a really
funny moment where you talk to her at
the at the gates to the city with all
the refugees everywhere and she's like I
do not understand why they're not
allowing these refugees into the City
and then you can respond like wow I
didn't think you of all people would
would help refugees and was help them we
can use the labor and it makes me think
like it's something like that I'm
paraphrasing but it's really funny and
I'm kind of like I I I don't see
anything wrong with that what is wrong
with someone coming to this country and
saying please help me I need Asylum and
our response being I got to be honest I
don't know or care if you need Asylum
you come here we put you to
work what what what's what's the moral
failing of that well I I don't think
there's a moral failing but I think that
already happens and I I don't think it's
a great system Ian no no no no I'm sorry
they're unleashing these people into
into cities and giving them cash and
putting them in hotels I'm saying like
Okay what job can you do and we're going
to make you work I suppose the problem
is is it disrupts the economy for uh
lower skilled labor in the United States
we trying to make money for themselves
exactly I mean this is something that
when um if I'm remembering this
correctly when um Reagan and Carter were
uh I can't talk right now when Reagan
and Carter were both running for
president uh Carter won West Virginia in
part because West Virginia were
concerned about the effect of
immigration on the country right like
places with uh lower skilled or maybe
union workers ultimately are the ones
who feel the brunt of it it's not people
who have Elite White Collar jobs who
feel the effects of of immigration the
same way and I think I mean Larry Elder
when he were here weight talked about
the fact that uh inner city black men or
black communities are disproportionately
affected by illegal immigration because
of the disruption to the economy I think
Al ultimately you can also say that this
is sort of one of the like like I
remember being in high school and having
this conversation with someone and he
was like well you're not going to pick
food out of a farm and you want to be
like so you admit that you see them as
inferior workers you how much here to do
backbreaking labor fruit harvesting gets
paid like uh this was this was 10 years
ago I went to farms in California 15 to
20 bucks an hour M no joke and they had
illegal immigrants working there I
talked to some uh young kids who were
skateboarding and I asked them like you
know what do you think about what's
going on there's these controversies and
they said their parents are uh
undocumented and so they were born here
but their parents they they work and
they're scared about what's going to
happen with Trump and all that and I was
like how much do you how much do you
guys make picking fruit here and they're
like uh like $15 starting but if you've
been here for a while it's like 20 bucks
an hour and I'm like I know a lot of
Americans who would love to make 20
bucks an hour just picking fruit the
other thing is that undocumented workers
or undocumented miners who come across
border if they're teenagers whatever are
often the people who will work
undetected they'll be you'll see these
cases where it's like com big
manufacturing plant or Whatever Gets
Busted for child labor and then
typically you can find out in the
release that the children are actually
undocumented in some capacity because
you know they're not necessarily
expected to be in school or whatever
else because they're not registered in
the same way that American SS are
meaning that they're not protected from
some of the abuses we wouldn't subject
our own children to I got it if I was
the mayor of New York you I'd be doing
or Chicago I'd build a
pyramid like the Bass Pro Shot pyramid
just a bunch of rocks you know what I
because I'm thinking like my question
about the moral failings of saying you
can come here but you have to work is
not about the economics which we we
understand we understand that disrupting
the economy is bad the question is is it
morally wrong to make an asylum Seeker
do
no no no I don't think so I think you
know if you come to my house and say can
I crash on your couch I'll be like do
the dishes and vacuum the floors and you
contribute and you can say here like
I'll pay the rent cover the utilities
you you you you Pro you like we we we we
trade right but what do you do what what
what could Eric Adams do you can't
Deport deporting internally in the
United States just means putting on a
bus and send him somewhere else that's
basically what H was happening with the
santis and and and Texas that's what
juliani did to the homeless that's right
I got in my neck of the woods yeah but
what if and and and you you don't want
to put them to work because then they're
going to disrupt low skill waor uh low
skill labor waer labor for the people
who live in the city thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net